hello and a very warm welcome indeed to
this latest edition of talking germany
the show where we do just that and my
guest today is a fascinating and rather
unusual man because he is an expert on
get this aggression here he is in person
yeah
jens weidner
he's come all the way from hamburg to be
with us thank you very much for joining
us here on talking germany today now
professor weidner is an educationalist
and criminologist whose specialist field
is the prevention of aggression and
violence but as i understand it he also
actually encourages the deliberate use
he's nodding while i'm saying this he
encourages get this the deliberate use
of aggression in the workplace to help
people to get to where they deserve to
be
i got it right yeah that's why that was
really fantastic
thank you wonderful right
you begin with a little bit of praise
for me i'm going to begin in a way
that's rather unusual one golden rule
for a talk show is that you should begin
with something that's sort of a little
bit feel good a little bit happy i would
however like to break all the rules and
begin with a quote from an english
philosopher over 300 years ago thomas
hobbes by the name yeah who said life is
nasty brutish and short
exactly
lupus
and he says homo harmony lupus man is
man's wolf
it's very nice that you quote the only
english philosopher i know it makes me
look like quite an educated type
hobbes
yes he sheds light on the evil in people
the dark side
he's a representative of pessimistic
anthropology he acknowledged correctly
that people are not naturally good we
all know that culture and religion help
us to become better people but not all
germans have managed that
but he is an interesting philosopher and
doesn't shy away from illuminating our
dark side
okay we'll talk about evil in a little
bit but it is it is your contention
professor weidner that human beings are
naturally aggressive naturally
competitive absolutely
the ability to love and to be aggressive
is part of us from birth
libido and thanatos as they say in
psychoanalysis
i don't know much about love but i do
know about aggression
for 10 years i worked with violent
offenders
hooligans skinheads
infamous thugs
skinheads
people who like to get into fights and
even kill others
as you can imagine i mostly bumped into
them when they were already in prison
where they belong and where they can be
treated
you get to know a lot of interesting
characters there
okay you you're talking about that
you're talking about the world of crime
there are people people in prisons what
about yourself are you a peace loving
person
venma netsumer as long as you're nice to
me
but basically i try to appear as
cultivated as possible even if i'm not
i once asked my students during a
lecture how many crimes they had
committed and of course i acted as if i
hadn't committed any myself but once is
this show only being broadcast outside
of germany
by the time i was 21 i had committed
more than 20 crimes
some less serious than others there's no
need to go into that now
and i became a better person once i
started studying
if you don't then you tend to lose your
professorship in germany you have to
choose between being a professor or a
criminal
professional now i earn enough money
through legal means so there's no need
to do anything else
fascinating insights fascinating first
impressions there from jens weidner here
is more
aggressive young men are violent pimps
what's the best topic for a dissertation
that's just an example of the sort of
things jens weidner discusses with his
students
he's a professor for educational science
and criminology at the hamburg school
for applied sciences
the aggression researcher has lived and
worked in hamburg since 1995.
jens weidner has been fascinated with
aggression and how it can be controlled
for more than 30 years
he's developed several treatment
programs for violent adolescents and
co-founded the german institute for
confrontational pedagogy
in his opinion aggression can have its
useful side and so he also works as a
career coach and management consultant
insider was born in 1958 as a boy he
joined the scouts and as a young man he
was drawn to the united states
after studying social work he went to
philadelphia where he gathered some
crucial work experience working with
violent gang members
that experience laid the foundations for
his future work
the 56 year old professor has an eye for
the lighter side of life and a weakness
for good food
so he's often found exploring the
gourmet cuisine around hamburg's harbor
area
and today he's our guest on talking
germany jens veiden
what a life you live there in hamburg
deck chairs in front of the university
building and gourmet restaurants in the
middle of the day
oh yes that's hamburg do come to hamburg
one time it's one of germany's most
cultural places
i don't think there's a contradiction in
showing social engagement by paying lots
of taxes
and wanting to enjoy life at the same
time
in fact i think they go hand in hand
okay that's an interesting description
of hamburg yeah
yourself you talked about the criminal
side of yourself you talked about your
criminal past yeah
nevertheless i found an interesting
quote from you you said uh that you were
born on the sunny side of life
absolutely absolutely
but you can also see that by the fact
that i was never caught
i don't have a criminal record and i'd
like to stress that here
i came from a good home i was well
treated and in times of trouble i was
given a lot of support
i have a wife who still loves me after
30 years
and children a daughter and a son who
were kind to me
i have a decent job in a great city in
germany which is a very pleasant country
yes it's life on the sunny side
the doctor's a sunny side okay the sunny
side of life so you came from the sunny
side of life you had a family that
supported you that encouraged you what
what prompted you to to move towards
studying aggression violence that is
another question that's really hard to
answer
at some point i just realized that i can
do it
i was a really lazy student
i had a camper van and i was a wind
surfer whenever the wind got up i headed
off to zoo through the north sea and
skipped school
then i did an internship in the us and
spent half a year with violent gang
members in philadelphia
in philadelphia
what did you learn there oh
can become a specialist in his own field
i learned about an incredibly successful
way of treating people a method of
aggression therapy at glen mill schools
in philadelphia
i learned that a weak chested guy like
me can work with real thugs if there's a
good concept involved and it was a good
concept
describe the concept yeah
well they really focused on misbehavior
and with delinquent kids there's a lot
of misbehavior
the idea is to confront the small issues
and so prevent the big ones from
happening in the first place
in germany at the same time it was the
other way around
we let things go into a sort of
pseudo-tolerance and only get involved
when something big happens
that hasn't really proved itself as a
teaching concept
so i stole the american concept well i
asked my american colleagues for
permission and they gave it
i took it to germany and built up a
program to treat repeat violent
offenders and i got it officially
patented as well because i was afraid it
might be successful
and when you are successful there's
another german trait
can you quantify
the level of success that you have had
with this approach
we're treating about 3 000 thugs a year
in germany
but you won't end up in intensive care
it's still not nice to get hit but it's
not quite as painful
and the remaining half not only
reoffends but they get worse
i say that's despite our methods our
critics say it's because of that
you can't get academics to agree
listen you've talked about you talked
about you indicated that the hamburg is
a relatively prosperous city but it's a
mixed picture because hamburg is very
wealthy on the one hand oh yeah there
are also poorer quarters absolutely
you've talked about your experience
working with kids in philadelphia in new
york and in washington i think it was
how much is when we talk about where
where does all this aggression come from
how much is it has it got to do with how
people grew up in terms of sort of class
well there are two types on the one hand
a society that's not doing well
economically always produces losers in
this modernization process
people who aren't doing well
and who are left by the wayside and are
angry about it
some beat others up some take drugs some
commit suicide autistic scene it's not
nice
the better society works the better off
we are
you can see that in every statistical
chart
you can almost always say that
aggressive children had an aggressive
upbringing
there are german families that are
bringing their children up terribly
parents hit the children husbands at
their wives and children have to watch
because it's interesting you've shifted
you've shifted the balance a little bit
in the debate because i asked you about
society and about people's you know
whether people living in in poverty is
perhaps a root of aggression and now
you've shifted it on to the the family
yeah where's it where is the the sort of
the the line between those two or the
connection between those two aspects
from my experience the people we're
asked to treat are sent to us by a judge
it affects
and that's the best mixture if you want
your child to grow up to be a thug
okay
so
what we've learned a little bit is that
all of us can have good and bad emotions
depending on how we've been educated the
influences on us
all of us have the potential to be
aggressive including of course children
and the question is can we learn to
manage or perhaps to channel our anger
let's have a look
professor weidner do you actually work
with children who were sort of real
juniors they were the kind of kids that
we saw the beginning of that report
yeah
we just saw also works in the same way
as we do and he does a fine job
of course if you talk to kindergarten
helpers
or junior school teachers they'll tell
you sometimes
you've got some children who just stink
of trouble we have to address
what does that mean when you say
can you how do you how do they see this
yeah the reactions are exaggerated you
ask can you pass me the milk and they
knock the milk bottle over and say i'm
not giving you anything
and they're like this
and then they go to the teacher and
insult her with some word connected to a
woman's lower body
what is that
the kid will be six or eight and you've
got to talk to them of course you can't
grill them you have to make it into a
game
you show the little boy that he won't
lose face
if he finds another way to resolve it
you can apologize and find that everyone
will praise you it's very important
isn't it the the ability to be able to
say sorry is very very important
it's very important
i also work in the area of management
so if you make a mistake on friday you
can go and apologize to your colleague
on monday i'd always do it on monday so
they can sweat over it over the whole
weekend
that was a joke by the way
that's why
yeah listen listen to listen uh we're
talking about germany germany is the
backdrop to what we're talking about
here germany likes to view itself as a
peace-loving society is it a
peace-loving society you laugh when i
ask the question does this let the
germans continue to do so
after all we started two world wars
we murdered vast numbers of people in
factories
so there is good reason for this country
to be as peaceful as it can be
but in business matters we're far from
peaceful we act all cultivated we don't
make hostile takeovers we just buy up
the company
german firms are trying hard to be top
global players and once they reach a
certain size and strength they can start
acting all cultivated
but they know when they can play an
aggressive game germans are not violent
per se
but they're also not naive
and that's how we want to do business
i was in birmingham recently
i gave a lecture and once again my
english wasn't good enough
i must explain is a little bit ashamed
of the fact that his english isn't as
good as the rest of his sort of package
yeah
after 30 minutes a british academic said
to me that i was coming across like a
tank
and i thought there they go again the
brits are trying to provoke me
and that's the problem
the people of hamburg love brits
but it's only partially requited
it's a bit one-sided
although i can tell you that you are
very well disposed to me
okay let's get back to
let's get back to the problem uh the the
problems that are sometimes posed by
young people here in germany youth
violence is something that people talk a
lot about in germany yeah is it on the
rise is it is it a more serious threat
than it has been in the past and how do
you deal with it a lot of people a lot
of the politicians say boot camps is the
right approach and get tough approach
are they right are they wrong
boot camps wrong well boot camps are
wrong
youth crime and violence in germany
comes and goes in waves
but on the whole it's going down
and not just in people's heads because
it's reported more heavily
in my area of study we call it media
one criminology act of violence gets
covered by 10 tv channels 20 newspapers
or more
they report on the act itself on the
trial and on the verdict
three times and everyone thinks the
country is being overrun by brutal gangs
of youth
that's not really what this country is
like
it's one of the safest countries in the
world but that's still a problem
what works
and what we're doing here is when
something happens we react straight away
boot camps are more militaristic and the
americans really love them
in germany there's no point in
discussing them we don't work like that
okay with your expertise with your
knowledge in the field your great
knowledge in the field can you when you
enter a room can you do you look at
people and do you identify the people
who have got a sort of a
a a higher
potential for aggression
i can smell that quickly
i'll be sitting on
that's a great way to get here
i was in with them for 8 10 12 hours a
day you can tell
but they smell me too
you can also tell with managers when
they're trying to be all peaceful but
inside they're exploding
boiling
yes you can feel it
there are people and as we're talking
about germany here there are a lot of
people in germany where you know coming
from other countries people are often
surprised by how many people say you
know i don't have an aggressive bone in
my body i am a non-aggressive person
yeah does such a if if somebody says
that to you what do you think
i think they're lying
everyone has aggression in them
they can try to be cultivated about it
i try to do that too with my aggression
i do sports that helps i have revenge
fantasies that's also a big help
but
your imagination is outside legal
jurisdiction you can do whatever you
want
that's a help to me and to many others
but there are people who deny that and
that's not funny
they often become auto-aggressive they
start to drink too much or try to bury
their feelings of guilt inside
it's not really healthy to be
auto-aggressive but anyone who says to
themselves i'm completely peaceful
doesn't exist they're lying
one last question here before we move on
uh have you used your own
anti-aggression therapy strategies on
yourself
do you sometimes have moments where
you're fuming or you're about to lose
your top and then you say to yourself
and what do you do
yes
i try not to react
i remember a therapy session where we
were doing provocation tests
such as when someone says
whenever anyone touches my knee i freak
out and hit them
so we touch his knee don't worry i won't
try it on you
personally for some reason i hate it
when someone fiddles around with my tie
i don't know how this thug figured it
out but he started fiddling around with
my tie and i started getting more and
more aggressive and i was about to smack
him one when i remembered
i'm the therapist
you can't do that
i'm supposed to be in control but we all
have these weak spots and i say i just
admit it and learn to live with it
it's okay
when i was younger what i used to do if
somebody if somebody annoyed me what i
would do is count to three one two three
before even beginning to react this is a
good you know what i do now
i count to four
to four
works even better yeah now it would seem
that in the corporate world there are
two main ways of motivating employees
number one is give people the feeling
that they are involved that they are
part of a team number two rivalry
competition dog against dog i personally
am a wishy washy team player maybe i
need some advice from jens weidner but
first this report
so
professor what
i said before that report that i am a
wishy-washy team player type and what we
saw in that report was that uh companies
that have wishy-washy team-playing
structures
actually do quite well but you go into
the companies and you say guys be
ferocious be fierce use your elbows
no not at all
you clearly haven't prepared this
interview very well
i think team play is great when it works
when people work together
when i have a great idea and share it
with you and you make it even better
that's a real win-win for all of us
but there's another reality a different
one
you see they said you had a sense of
humor
hot pepper
management
when you hear the term lean management
that's another way of saying
unemployment for career-minded people in
germany
it's when we restructure
when we say
we're going to slim down the company or
we have to fire some people and others
will have to go to work at the plant in
kazakhstan
and i want people to see through the
power games that are played
hey that's on page 172 of my book and he
looked it up and said
there's no point in doing that with you
i said i know and then we get a
perfectly normal chat about it
explaining power structures to workers
is liberating absolutely yeah
i'd say be 80 a good person gentleman
like that's enough but add 20 percent
bloody mindedness as they say in munich
interfaith
respect is the product of your fairness
your special skills
and a touch of fear and that's what the
twenty percent accounts for the fear
it's interesting it is about making
other people just a little bit
frightened yes the other side's got to
know that if they play with me it's
going to cost them
okay and when you are when you are
helping people to develop their skills
and their understanding and their
capacities in this direction are you
talking more to women or talking more to
men it would seem to me that women have
the greater
deficit because we're told all the time
that women are less aggressive than men
okay now you're going to get lots of
complaints from your female viewers
just because they're blunt
they want to make a clear statement and
we are helping them
it's good if other people can see that
you're not just good
it's enough to be loved by your wife
your mother-in-law and your pets
and when it comes to your job
you want people to think you're fair
and you want them to respect you but
please don't try to be loved
okay
there's a personal aspect to all that
you're telling me because because i i
understand that there's a quote i've got
a quote from you until i was 34 years
old yeah
i was one of the sheep you said yeah uh
what was the tell me a little bit more
about the uh the sheepish jensfeidner
that's how english i say that
well it's true
sheep are people who put 100 into their
jobs
i worked myself stupid i was exhausted
i wanted to get ahead so
that's typically german
but i never got promoted and i never
understood why
i applied for another job but i didn't
get it
i never understood why none of my job
applications were successful
and he said
you really didn't get it
i said no
and he said
when you applied somewhere they rang me
and asked me what i thought of you and i
said he's a great guy top class super
chap
a real bonus to have him working for you
and they all said they'd take
his answer was he was a funny sort of
guy he said
you've worked so hard for me
that i've got my golf handicap down
under 10.
welcome to germany
not everyone is like that
but it happens yeah
isn't trying to get people to be less or
more aggressive he enjoys being and
these are his own words on really boring
islands well germany's north coast
certainly has quite a few to choose from
and one of the professor's favorites is
i'm going to the pronunciation is
difficult for me langer org in east
frisia i think i got it right
on the horizon longao comes into view
with its seemingly endless sandy beaches
there are no taxis or buses waiting the
island railway takes visitors from the
port to the town in less than 10 minutes
everything can be reached from here but
only on foot or by bicycle in the
tourist season it can get crowded
in the dune belt by contrast there's
nothing but peace and quiet
like all the east frisian islands
langaog has a wild and gentle side
windswept beaches face the side open to
the north sea
on the side facing the mainland are the
tidal mud flats of the wadden sea
twice every 24 hours the water recedes
revealing one of the world's richest
habitats our guide takes us through the
shallow water and opens our eyes to life
in the mud
from the tiny mud snail to the fat lug
worm
this is my first time here and i'm
amazed by all you can find it's so
incredibly beautiful
we'll definitely come again
i think it's great how he explains
everything and it's fun to walk through
the mud and eat this marsh samphire it's
great and exciting
environmental scientist pierta
weinbecker introduces us to lange oaks
bird life
arctic breeders stopped to rest here on
the vadden sea
bar-tailed godwits herring gulls and
sandpipers
the wadden sea is also a nursery for
seals they come in late may from the
open north sea and populate the
sandbanks
you can get quite close to them on a
cutter
living in tune with the seasons requires
close observation of nature the
islanders do that as a matter of course
it's the only way they can deal with
nature's forces
against weiner you know the island very
well indeed just tell me did i get the
pronunciation right linga org perfect
good what does it mean
it means a long island
it's stretched out with more than 20
kilometers of sandy beaches
when i say long i mean it fantasticians
at a city dweller in a fantastic way
i hardly meet anyone for 20 kilometers i
feel like robinson crusoe
when it's foggy the sand the fog and the
sky
all blur into one and you don't know
where you're running i feel like god
expensive cars expensive suits expensive
houses you don't get that online org on
the contrary that's why so many people
love it including my family
very interesting the democrat jens
weidner there yeah making putting in his
plea for our equality in german society
yeah
um
tell me about the mud flats this vata
vandarong that the germans sir so love
it's something that's just not familiar
to me at all what's the great attraction
there
i never go hiking in it because it's too
muddy i prefer the sand
i know some people love it but i'm not
so keen on it
there's something called a what cake
i love
but you get that from a bakery
no i really don't like walking on the
mud flats but there is one more but on
this very very boring boring boring
island there is one more attraction
apart from the fact that the highest
elevation is 21 meters high i discovered
that's the milk hern dune
yeah you've been up it all the way to
the top yeah hamburger i'm coming from
hamburg i don't really like hills but
that's one i feel at home
you've conquered it yeah yes when i'm up
there i feel really high up
how do the police and how do doctors get
around the island
yeah i skipped that kind of well there
aren't really anything
there are two electric cars one is the
ambulance in case anyone has an accident
on the mud flats to get into a ship
and one to carry water crates in so we
have something to drink
they're too heavy
they drink a lot there
apart from that it's just quiet
and you too have a bike for getting
around the island i have a bike i rent
it there and cycle around
interesting because you're a car man
aren't you you've got a reputation for
being a
you're a sports car
i prefer a german brand by the name of
porsche
one of the best known uh
examples of controlled aggression on
four wheels absolutely by partial
missiles to be sure with a porsche you
don't need to be aggressive i just drive
and people get out of my way it's
fantastic but i do have to tell anyone
watching that i only buy these cars from
the income from the books iran
right now i'm trying to make a new
investment
bin okay we've got to move on we're
gonna we're talking the books we're
gonna talk about a book that's lying
down here on the table in a second but
before we get there there's one thing
that we have forgotten to talk about
that you mentioned in passing we've
talked about you know whether people are
naturally aggressive or not we've talked
about sort of the you know the human
condition
one thing we haven't talked about really
properly is evil you have met a lot of
people in prisons you have met a lot of
people who have committed
serious serious crimes cruel crimes is
evil a useful category for
for describing people
and for working with people or
understanding them in some way
when we are criminal when we think of
criminals that accounts for maybe five
percent of them
most criminals can be helped with
treatment or re-socialization
but there is a small percentage where we
have to get the psychologist
they're really
in germany they say the maximum penalty
is a life sentence and that means 15
years
but i know a lot of people who have been
in jail for 35 years in this country
they probably should be too yes some
people really are evil
okay
and talking about evil talking about
good and evil we like to get our guests
to bring along a cherished possession
this is your cherished possession you
pulled it out of your jacket earlier
yeah gurt is faust yeah a tale of good
and evil really yeah
yeah yes
well to begin with faust is part of
german culture
he really was an educated man much more
than i am
i never managed to understand false part
two no matter how clever it is
but in fast part one he describes life
the way it really is
the way he treats gretchen the way he
treats women so things work out
i've been happily married for 30 years
and you learn a lot about how people are
mentioned
a terrible tragic end that uh comes to
grace
all right you don't have to make the
same mistakes as faust makes in the end
but you learned something from mephisto
that people often want to do good and
end up doing evil
and is this duality that captures the
essence of life so well and in rhyme
form over hundreds of pages
and when you're reading your wee little
faust book yeah do you identify more
with good with with faust and his
striving for knowledge or do you
identify more you personally with
mephistopheles
just mephisto
i think he uses irony and humor in his
mephistophelian way to reveal the dark
sides of our world
and that's my job too
i describe and treat the dark sides of
violent offenders and i often see the
dark sides of managers too and sometimes
i'd like to make them even darker
you're talking there about the dark side
of the human persona once again i know
that you are a member final question of
a club in hamburg called the optimists
club yeah what are you so optimistic
about
yeah first off i believe in the good
enough
people can be changed for the good i'm
relieved
germans have this reputation for being
maudlin and moani
really
it's always said i don't know i don't
know it's very good
well that's why we founded the optimists
club along with people who when things
are going badly still say their glass is
half full
and i like that
and they laugh a lot
normally yen spider at the end of the
show the music is coming up we have a
quiz i only have time for one question
are human beings fundamentally good or
fundamentally bad
good good good that is your lot with
jens feidner what a fascinating guest he
has been if you've enjoyed this company
as much as i have then do come back next
week until then bye bye and
you